THE SENTIMENT AROUND BING:
What’s the first words that come
to mind when you think of Bing? For most of you,
it’s probably: slow, old, crappy, buggy, inferior,
and unappealing. I don’t blame you as Bing is
associated with Microsoft which is associated
with Internet Explorer, and we all know how bad
Internet Explorer was. In terms of market share,
it seems like the whole world agrees. While
Bing’s marketshare has been rising within
the desktop market, it’s still struggling to crack
even 3% while Google stands at a towering 93%. So,
this seems like an open and shut case. Google
dominates and Bing sucks right? Well, in terms
of popularity that’s true, but the same cannot
be said about profitability. Bing is actually
substantially more lucrative than Google in
terms of per user revenue. In 2022, for example,
Bing pulled in a total of $11.59 billion worth
of revenue. This means that for every percentage
of marketshare, they pull in $3.83 billion.
Conversely, in 2022, Google’s search business
pulled in a total of $162.5 billion. While their
overall revenue blows Bing out of the water,
their revenue per percentage of marketshare
comes in at less than half of Bing at $1.75
billion. In other words, Bing is over twice as
lucrative as Google from a per user standpoint.
If Google was as lucrative as Bing, their search
revenue itself would jump to $355 billion. So,
while Bing isn’t nearly as large as Google, it
does seem like they’ve been able to carve out an
extremely lucrative portion of the market.
But, this wasn’t always the case. In fact,
about ten years ago, Bing was losing money
hand over fist. During the worst of it,
Microsoft was losing over $1 billion every single
quarter with Bing, and they were down a total of
$5.5 billion within just the first two years.
But, after Satya Nadella took over, Bing would
finally become profitable in late 2015. And since
then, it’s only gotten more and more lucrative. We
should also mention that Bing’s new ChatGPT
powered search feature has had a far better
launch to Google’s. So, here’s how Bing went from
abject failure to holding it’s own against Google.
ATTRACTING USERS:
Before Bing could worry
about profitability, they first had to build a
user base. You would think that the popularity of
Microsoft and Windows would make this easy, but
this wasn’t exactly the case because Microsoft
was always fighting an uphill battle with Bing.
Here’s the thing, Bing came out in mid 2009 which
was during the peak of the ditch internet explorer
movement. In 2008, IE had nearly 70% market share,
but this would plummet to less than 30% by the end
of 2013. This meant that Microsoft not only had to
convince people to stay on IE, but to also ditch
Google and start using Bing. As you would guess,
this didn’t really play out all that well
leading to the massive losses in Bing’s
early history. But, Microsoft wasn’t willing to
just give in to Google. So, they started looking
for ways to grow their user base which leads
us to their two key strategies starting with
incentives. Microsoft basically decided to pay
users to use Bing with their rewards program.
If you’re not familiar with Bing Rewards, it’s
actually quite appealing. As a new Bing user,
you’ll be paid 5 points per search for your first
10 searches everyday. Once you start using Bing
regularly and Microsoft can verify that you’re
not just spamming searches to earn more points,
you’ll be upgraded to level 2 which is a lot more
lucrative. At level 2, you can earn up to 250
points per day which translates to 50 incentivized
searches. Each point is roughly worth a tenth of
a cent, so 50 searches is worth about 25 cents.
Clearly, switching to Bing isn’t gonna make you
millionaire, but it can get you a free Chipotle
every month which is a pretty good deal for just
going about your daily business with Bing.
It appears that a lot of people feel this way
given that there’s a massive reddit community with
over a 100,000 users who focus on just maximizing
the value of rewards points. I mean, these people
have it down to a science. This user for example
broke down every rewards point avenue and
calculated that you can earn up to $22.50
every month using Microsoft’s various offerings.
Clearly, Microsoft’s been able to create a pretty
dedicated community, but bribing isn’t their
only avenue of growth. Much of Bing’s search
volume comes from their dozens of partnerships
and deals. Microsoft has basically partnered
with everyone that’s not Google. The most notable
of these include Yahoo, AOL, DuckDuckGo, Lycos,
and Ecosia. It’s not just search providers
that Microsoft has partnered with either.
Several years ago, they partnered with Amazon and
entered the ecommerce space. And more recently,
they partnered with Shopify to bring merchant
listings to Bing. On top of all this, Microsoft
has also integrated Bing into all of their product
offerings. For example, if you’re searching on
Cortana, the Xbox, Microsoft Edge, or the Windows
Search Bar, you’re gonna be directed to Bing
unless you manually change your default search
engine. And when you put all of this together,
you get a userbase that can only be beaten out
by Google, and now it was time to monetize.
SUPERIOR DEMOGRAPHICS:
While Bing was able to grow a pretty sizeable user
base, one of it’s biggest shortfalls is that none
of it’s users are exactly choosing Bing due to
its search merits. As we discussed, much of Bing’s
user base comes from Microsoft’s existing products
and partnerships or bribery. So, how could such a
platform become more lucrative than Google? Well,
the answer is superior demographics. I mean,
just think about it, what type of person would
switch to Bing just to earn a couple of dollars
every month? Well, it’s not the average person
because the average person is be too concerned
with staying socially acceptable. The type
of person who switches to Bing is the type
of person who’s obsessed with credit card points,
airline points, and hotel points. They probably
keep around their broken phone for 8 months just
so they can save $100 bucks on black friday. And
they’re the ones that scam car salesmen. But,
just because they’re so conscious of their
spending doesn’t mean they’re broke. In fact,
they’re usually the most well off which means
that they’re extremely valuable ad targets. Now,
let’s be clear here, you’re not gonna sell these
guys on the new iPhone or HBO Max. But, an AmEx
platinum with a 200,000 point sign up bonus? Now,
we’re talking. These people are also the most
likely to entertain insurance ads, mortgage ads,
and fintech product ads. In fact, 30 to 40%
of all searches on Bing are related to travel,
cars, health, and finances. Meanwhile, these are
the top searches on Google. It’s basically just
social media platforms, retailers, and food.
While Google’s searches may be more relatable,
Bing’s searches are far more lucrative when it
comes to adsense because the long term value of
these products are sky high. With mortgages, for
example, banks can make hundreds of thousands of
dollars with each sale, so naturally, they pay a
lot more to advertise their products than Walmart
or Starbucks. We should also note that Bing’s user
base tends to be older with a median age of 45.
And given that people tend to get wealthier
with age, this is once again a win for Bing.
It’s not just the financial demographics that are
working in Bing’s favor either. Bing also tends to
benefit from having more desktop users. As we
previously touched on, much of Bing’s success
is attributable to the desktop space where they
almost have 10% market share. They’re virtually
non existent within the mobile space, but this
isn’t exactly a bad thing because desktop users
tend to be far more valuable. Desktop users
tend to visit far more sites and they spend
far more time on each site as well. In 2020,
for example, the average mobile user visited
2.67 sites while the average desktop user visited
3.95 sites. Similarly the average mobile user only
spent 160 seconds on each site while the average
desktop user spent 351 seconds on each site. So,
naturally, Bing is going to benefit from having
a more lucrative demographic than Google.
THE NEW MICROSOFT:
We’ve primarily been discussing quantitative
points as to how Bing is progressing,
but the reality is that much of Bing’s success
actually has to do with qualitative points,
and especially the new Microsoft philosophy.
Before Satya Nadella, the Microsoft philosophy was
that Microsoft is the absolute best company and
that everyone should use everything from Microsoft
whether that’s the Windows Phone or MSN Messenger.
But, Satya brought a much softer perspective to
Microsoft. Since 2015, Microsoft’s approach has
been more of: how do we combine our hits with our
competitors’ hits to create the absolute best
product as opposed to how do we replicate our
competitors’ success by ourselves. In other words,
Microsoft has shed much of their ego and they’re
much more open to collaboration. For example,
they launched Office on iOS. But, by far their
most humble move of all time was their decision
to ditch their in house browser engine and switch
to Google’s Chromium which has done wonders for
Edge. It appears that Microsoft is bringing the
same approach to Bing as well. The old Microsoft
would’ve probably just pushed out updated version
of Cortana and that would’ve been their AI
offering. But, the new Microsoft is embracing
ChatGPT all the way. Meanwhile, it appears that
Google still has Microsoft’s old mindset. They’re
want everyone to use Google everything. They want
you to have a google phone, a google os, a google
search engine, a google ai, a google security
system, and even a google based smart home. While
this approach has worked for them so well, it’s
only a matter of time until someone does something
better than Google. This already happened in
the social media, video conferencing space, and
self driving space. I mean, Facebook destroyed
Google+, Zoom and Teams are destroying Hangouts,
and Tesla is destroying Waymo. None of this has
really hurt Google though because these industries
didn’t affect their main business. However, the
same cannot be said about ChatGPT. ChatGPT is a
direct replacement to traditional search engines
and it’s already doing extraordinarily well. Now,
Google does have their own version of ChatGPT
called Google Bard which is supposed to come
out soon. And who knows, it could be way better
than ChatGPT, but we should note that initial
impressions aren’t giving it much credit. I mean
just take a look at this. Microsoft was able
to get 1 million people on a waitlist within 48
hours for the new ChatGPT powered Bing. Meanwhile,
Google ended up losing $100 billion worth of
marketcap after their Bard announcement. Now, for
all we know, Bard could be a massive success, but
this is just the latest example of Google being
stuck in their ways just like most companies.
Microsoft, however, has become surprisingly
flexible, and I’d bet that this will turn out
to be far more sustainable over the long term.
THE FUTURE OF BING:
In the end, Bing
came out during a time when Microsoft hate was at
an absolute peak. People hated IE and people hated
Windows 8, so naturally, they didn’t want to try
anything that came out of Microsoft. Consequently,
Microsoft ended up losing billions with Bing
within the first few years. They were able to
turn this around by offering appealing
incentives and making key partnerships
which attracted quite a lucrative user base.
But, the real turnaround for Bing didn’t come
until Microsoft stopped forcing their products to
an intolerable level. For the first time, people
actually started to use Edge and Bing out of
free will. And now, 1 million people are excited
for a ChatGPT powered Bing. I mean, just think
about that: they’re excited for Bing. Clearly,
Microsoft is turning things around in a ginormous
way. And who knows, in a decade, Bing may not only
be the more lucrative search engine but also
the larger search engine. Are you guys excited
for the new Bing? Comment that down below. Also,
drop a like if you like to see actual competition
in the search space. And of course, consider
checking out our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.